okay we're here tonight at fling boxes
launch of season three of Game of
Thrones or what are you looking forward
to I am a huge Game of Thrones fan I
know this might sounds a little bit
grand but it probably is my favorite
television series ever well it's just a
fantastic story
um the storyline you never know what to
expect and that seems to be a theme of
doing away with the best characters I
wouldn't be here if I wasn't a game of
Thrones head being eight months pregnant
and it being boiling I they's dedication
to the course yes I'm a huge fan crazy I
look on Twitter and his people from
Argentina
you know it's girls stand off your
tweets can you could stuff inside that
world whose role do you like to take and
how do you think you get on in Westeros
if it was real oh it would definitely
have to be the role of Khaleesi because
she is totally awesome and there
sometimes it can I eat really frustrates
me because they save her bits till the
end because she's the best character in
my eyes and I'd like to think that I'd
be able to free some slaves and like I
guess keep the men in check she does a
very good job of that but now I think
she's totally stunning as well and she
just she seemed really nice
you know you think I hope she'd be
really nice in real life because her
character is just fabulous
so definitely cleasing my favorite
character though apart from jon snow
would be tyrion i like his sense of
humor very dry very witty and he gets
all the girls
oh goodness me well do you know what I
was tweeting honey about what do you
were to an official game of Thrones
launch no because the costumes are so
fabulous and I was thinking well you
know you don't really want to do the
kind of the stark chic which is you know
the big black fur and leather kind of
thing you know
so Bay it's a bit hot for that so I was
thinking you know it would definitely be
Targaryen sort of a tide sheet with lots
of gold kind of chic you know sort of
Elizabeth Taylor and Cleopatra springs
to mind but she's not in it obviously
but that sort of thing you know they
liked they liked a lot of bling
didn't they so
we've had the red wedding in season
three haven't we what did you make of
that what was your reaction to all those
deaths I couldn't believe it
really I don't know that's all how could
he do it I did a vine I mean - fine I
can actually watch the episode I heard
it come out and I was on Twitter and
everyone was going great yeah I hate new
why is it a vine it's like a video thing
where you're pressing the screen it
records as well as doing a minute go
okay um sorry I hadn't watched the
episode but everyone's going crazy on
Twitter so I thought I'd do a little
reaction and then I actually watched the
episode afterwards it was kind of like
oh that was really unsympathetic because
it was really sad the red wedding that
was absolutely also a couple either that
Robb Stark went to be honest I mean he
was such a strong character and I
thought he would be nice throughout and
you just like please stop dude all these
characters that you're so involved with
and for yeah what what a shocker that
Robb Stark went I couldn't believe that
one literally it was one of those
moments where you just have to see in
silence afterwards and digest what just
happened and but that's what's great
about it keeps you guessing and it's not
all about happy endings and then I think
that's yeah that's quite refreshing as
well the one thing that I'm worried
about is coming to the Tower of London
which also if you've been network I've
been watching the White Queen at the
same time so I'm terrified that somehow
somebody's got to cut my belly open and
my baby's gonna die you know sorry I'm
being very overdramatic there but
yes I did watch it and I was a dog and a
gas you know calmly work can't believe
it but what I actually really liked
about it is it it opens the way for
things to come because obviously you've
got the Dragons growing up you know that
you've seen you've almost think you've
seen flashes into the future of that so
I think that the Targaryen is coming
back to throne could be really
interesting I she's really interesting
but also Jon Snow's really interesting
and then you've got his contender who's
also the bastard son of the the other
King so the and he's not a Lannister the
Lannisters I love to hate yeah and the
Lannisters I really love to hate you
know and of course and they do it so
well
you've got fabulous female characters on
the show haven't they what do you think
of Cersei yeah Oh
Cersei the snake Cersei the snake I mean
you know as a fantasy character you know
it's R it's like pantomime you sort of
boo and hiss don't you like snow oh you
[ __ ] ah like this but they've played so
well that you really get psyched up
along with the drama and so you just
can't not care if you were in that world
of Westeros and you had to have one of
those striking deaths I have on the show
how would you like to go out well being
at the Tower of London there's got be a
beheading the Dragons the Dragons are
absolutely awesome or one OPSEC Lisa
she's my favorite but I love it when the
Dragons come out and they're so well
done the effects are awesome
I think I'd like to be burnt by dragon
every time I see him I'm like if I don't
die do i and he just laughed this is a
little giggle and I'm like no you can't
do that do you never know but you know
if if we did that's right we've had a
great time but I'd imagine a solid but I
think the main thing is there
yeah the method of of you of death thing
I wouldn't here be ready you know if you
just saw if you had an accident and died
of Game of Thrones that'd be really
really suck yeah you like something off
one of those personal injury claim
slipped on some yeah what is a bit at
the style of the show that you like
they've got a do take great costumes
that's one of the things they've been
nominated for an Emmy today I didn't
know that that's amazing they've been
nominated for an Emmy
I think the variation is incredible you
know it really is the variation through
costume set the art direction the way it
changes obviously you know when you see
the map at the beginning I mean the
introduction is so long it really isn't
so long but it I like watching every
time because you pick up a different
detail of you know and it's obviously
fantasy but you see you sort of see the
continents before magically before they
shifted kind of thing so you think well
the Targaryen would be in Greece so
you've got a kind of Grecian vibe and I
just love the attention to detail that
goes through all of those different
things - really so to really define
these these different plants and to
divine
how big this land is yeah it's fantastic
we've got quite free last year I heard
the news earlier today it's just
fantastic and it's great because there's
so many people who really deserve that
like the amount the attention to detail
that goes into everything and all the
different departments and stuff so yeah
I'm glad that's been recognized
there's just so much great television
around for the moment so to be
considered a monster amongst the best of
it
it's brilliant a like mazing so like
loads of deserving people I think Game
of Thrones histone are such a huge scale
the sets are amazing the costumes are
amazing the actors and actresses are
amazing everything about it is just
quality television and nothing seems
like it's drawing on the Chi and it just
keeps you hooked and what's just
frustrating is having to wait for that
next episode of that next series so it's
great that it's comfortably books
you